how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and
everything relating to the mcu and today
we are going to talk about a film that
people are calling
a mini avengers film and if that is a
little bit confusing
no i'm not talking about a young
avengers film but i'm talking about a
film that is going to be very similar to
what captain america
civil war was like captain america civil
war was just as much an avengers film as
it was a captain america film and not
only was captain america civil war
pretty much an avengers film but it was
an extremely important movie that set
the groundwork and the story for
avengers infinity war and avengers end
game so civil war was an extremely
important mcu film that had over 10
different heroes in it including most of
the avengers with the exception of the
hulk and
thor and a film like this is reportedly
what we're going to be getting in the
mcu
very very soon a film that is going to
introduce
at least a couple of new characters and
is going to set the groundwork for
the new avengers film and will pretty
much be introduced to the entire cast of
the new avengers in this film
so if you're excited about the future of
the mcu you're going to want to watch
this video because i'll be talking about
this new
mini avengers film that everybody is
talking about all the new characters
that have been reported for the film
that we can expect to see
and the new avengers i'll be breaking it
all down in this video
if you're new be sure to subscribe to
stay up to date on all the latest mcu
news and so you can enter this week's
giveaway for a chance to win a scarlet
witch
funko pop all you have to do to enter
subscribe like this video and leave a
comment down below i'm picking a winner
on monday
and if you love g fuel use code cosmic
for the next two days to get 30
off so we have several new reports all
from well-known sources claiming that a
new
mini avengers film is going to be coming
before avengers 5.
and it's actually kind of a brilliant
move by marvel and i'll explain why
all these reports are saying that this
mini avengers film is going to be
captain marvel 2.
according to these reports captain
marvel 2 is going to be very
very similar to captain america civil
war there is going to be tons of mcu
characters in the movie heroes and
villains and the film is going to
introduce new characters to the mcu as
well
just like captain america civil war did
now the reason i say that it's brilliant
is because some fans are still kind of
on the fence about captain marvel
she has a lot of love from a lot of fans
and the movie did very well in the box
office earning over a billion dollars
but there are still many people in the
fandom who thought the movie was only
okay
but by making captain marvel 2 just like
civil war kind of a mini
avengers film you're almost guaranteeing
that it'll be
a massive success and make over a
billion dollars at the box office
and kevin feige the president of marvel
studios has already confirmed that
captain marvel
is the future of the mcu she is going to
go on and lead
the new avengers team so captain marvel
2 will set up the new avengers and this
is coming from
three different reports and three
different sources and the first report
is coming from
mcu direct and their report states as
follows
according to a reliable source with
industry knowledge
ms marvel will appear in the sequel to
captain marvel
they go on to say that their sources
said that her appearance will be a
supporting role and
the captain marvel sequel will also
include many important
mcu characters with the film being
described as a mini
avengers film and to top the report off
they say that the film
will also adapt the secret invasion
comic storyline which has already been
rumored so according to their source
we're getting a mini avengers film with
captain marvel 2 and
miss marvel kamela khan is going to be
in the film as well
now marvel has already announced a miss
marvel disney plush show
and the president of marvel studios has
already said that these disney plus
shows take place in the mcu they are 100
going to affect what happens in the
marvel cinematic universe and they are
going to tie into the films
so you're going to have to watch these
disney plus shows that come out to keep
up with the mcu films
and real quick i've still been getting a
lot of questions about how to access
disney plus if it's not available in
your country and how to use a vpn to do
this
and the great news is it's not that hard
and it's not that expensive and i want
to thank surfsharkvpn for sponsoring
this video
i use surfshark for several different
reasons i use them as security to keep
my information private but i also use
them to access
netflix shows that aren't available in
the us how i met your mother is one of
my favorite shows and it's only
available on netflix in the uk right now
but with surf shark i connect to a uk
server and this enables me to be able to
watch how i met your mother and the same
can be done
with disney plus if disney plus is not
in your current country you can use surf
shark as a vpn to access a different
server in the united states where disney
plus
is available and watch disney plus and
all of its shows and
movies right now if you use my code
cosmic you can get 85
off plus three extra months for free
they also offer a 30-day money-back
guarantee so there's no risk to try it
out for yourself if you're looking to
try out a vpn
you can find the link to surfshark in
the description down below
now our second report comes from
mcucosmic.com
and in this report it says that captain
marvel 2 is meant to set the stage for
whatever the new avengers film is going
to be
just like captain america civil war set
the premise for
avengers infinity war because remember
infinity war pretty much took place
right after the events of civil war
where the avengers were pretty much
disbanded
and separated into different teams and
that was a big part of
infinity war and why the avengers failed
in the beginning
tony stark has to tell bruce banner that
the avengers disbanded that they broke
up like a boy band
god we haven't caught up in a spell
haven't we oh the avengers broke up
or toast broke up
like a band like like the beatles and
this is why the avengers originally lost
to thanos because they weren't all
fighting him together they fought him in
different groups and that was directly
caused by the events of civil war so
civil war played a huge role for
infinity war
and in game and now captain marvel 2 is
also going to play a major role in the
next
new avengers film and really what that
means is the introduction of new
characters and the inclusion of a lot of
existing characters already to make up
the new avengers team
and again this is going to be just like
civil war because civil war introduced
black panther
and spider-man two heroes two major
heroes introduced in a group film that
went on to have their own films which
were massive successes so marvel is
doing what they know
works now miss marvel is set to premiere
in the summer or
early fall of 2021 meaning that we'll
already have seen her in the mcu on
disney plus before she comes into
captain marvel 2.
so she's not exactly going to be new
which brings us into our third
report of new characters coming mikey
sutton has also reported that captain
marvel 2
is going to be a pretty big film
involving multiple heroes including
spider-man joining up with captain
marvel in the sequel but
the introduction of the super scroll a
possible
nova introduction in captain marvel 2
and one of our very first
x-men characters coming to the mcu rogue
as
one of the villains spider-man is
another character that is said to be
leading the new avengers team moving
forward in the mcu
so if captain marvel 2 is going to be as
big as everybody is saying that it's
going to be and it's going to be
a mini avengers film it would just make
sense that spider-man is there
and as far as nova is concerned captain
marvel is definitely a cosmic character
at the end of the first film she goes
off to help other planets and other
people in the universe
even in avengers in-game for pretty much
the entire film after the five-year gap
until the end
she's in different parts of the galaxy
and while she was out there in the
galaxy it's very possible that she could
have ran
into nova which is a great gateway to
lead to his introduction in captain
marvel 2. and according to mikey sutton
it looks like marvel studios is going to
be taking a page from the comics in
marvel team up number 62
where carol danvers back then miss
marvel and spider-man team up to fight
the super scroll and if there's a super
scroll that leads us to believe that
they're going to be other scroll
as well which are most likely not like
the good scroll that we saw in the first
film but are most likely bad
and that brings us back to the first
report that the plot of the movie is
going to be
secret invasion now as many of you know
either from the comics or the first
captain marvel film the scroll can
shapeshift and secret invasion was about
the invasion of the skrull who were
secretly replacing
many of the superheroes in the universe
with imposters
over a period of years and we've
actually already kind of seen this
in the mcu in spider-man far from home
nick fury and
maria hill were secretly talos and his
wife
now obviously talos and his wife are
good scroll
and they were working for nick fury and
what we presume to be
sword but there are bad scrolls out
there and with the super scroll coming
there could be the reality that the
scroll are actually shape-shifting into
some heroes that we know and love
and this could be why all of these
characters are going to be coming
together in captain marvel 2. to figure
out who's really
who which heroes are heroes and which
ones are impostors by scroll
this would give the illusion that the
heroes are fighting each other
when really they're fighting scrolls who
are impersonating them but this would
kind of be a way to give it that civil
war
feel heroes fighting heroes now the last
thing that mikey sutton has said about
captain marvel 2
is that rogue will be set up towards the
end to be a future main villain so that
could go on to set up the new avengers
plot
mutants now exist in the mcu and we're
going to find out that not all of them
are good
so if even a little bit of this ends up
becoming true captain marvel 2 is going
to be a
crazy insane film one that i will
definitely be
excited to watch especially with the
inclusion of many of the new avengers
characters like
captain marvel herself miss marvel
spider-man possibly
nova and if we're lucky maybe even a few
mutants but let me know what you think
about captain marvel 2 being a mini
avengers film would this get you excited
to watch captain marvel 2 and who would
you like to see show up
let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you can stay
up to date on all the latest
mcu news for live updates you can follow
me on twitter and as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof